there's something out there
stalking watching lying in wait for the
right moment it can be anywhere
disappear in the blink of an eye and
reappear somewhere else always poised
and ready to strike the scp foundation
has it locked up for now they keep a
tracking tag fixed to it so they can
find it whenever it gets out and believe
us it does get out so when it does you
should watch your back keep your woods
about you and check over your shoulder
if you hear something move if you aren't
careful it might come for you if you let
your guard slip even for just a second
you could be next mclean virginia it's
hardly a hotbed of anomalous activity
viola thought to herself as she pulled
up at an unassuming townhouse when she
first joined the scp foundation field
agent smithy had imagined her life to be
full of adventure battling anomalous
monsters and entities with the power to
rewrite reality itself instead she had
unwittingly pulled a short straw
somewhere along the way and now got
saddled with this retrieving an anomaly
that had gone missing viola had no idea
what to expect all she had been told was
that according to its tracking tag the
anomaly had teleported into one of three
potential relocation sites or prs's she
just happened to be the closest
available field agent stationed nearby
and was instructed to drive over and
collect it and return the escaped scp to
the foundation they had told agent
smithy it was harmless putting her guard
right down as she stepped inside the
house she wasn't prepared for the ambush
that awaited her the house codenamed prs
townhouse was silent practically
abandoned as she made her suite room by
room viola was methodically checking her
corners looking under beds inside
cupboards behind couches on top of
shelves making sure she'd covered every
single inch of the house whatever this
anomaly was it was good at hiding before
long agent smithy had checked the whole
house from top to bottom and had found
nothing no side of the elusive scp with
no idea where it was viola went into the
kitchen she figured she might as well
see if there was anything to eat in this
place maybe it had already gone she
thought she'd have to check in with bass
and see if the tracking tag was still
active at this location this thing could
teleport after all it could be
sunbathing in cancun by now drinking a
pina colada out of a coconut with a tiny
umbrella oh wouldn't that be the life
viola approached the refrigerator and
casually placed her hand on the door
with no idea what was waiting for her
inside she pulled it open and was
immediately hit in the face with a
pillow it wasn't traveling at any
substantial speed in fact it was like
having been lightly thrown by a human
hand more than anything else it didn't
knock field agent smithy back or send
her reeling or have enough force to
cause any injury instead the pillow just
softly impacted viola's face giving a
little squeak like a dog toy would
before it lazily fell onto the kitchen
floor fixed to one side of it was a
post-it note with a crudely drawn face
that glared up at her with a jagged
frown vial aside mildly annoyed that she
just had a pillow thrown at her now
after having spent half an hour
searching the house leaning down she
picked it up and radioed the foundation
she'd found scp-3832
but it didn't end there oh no
after they got the anomaly safely back
in its containment locker it wasn't long
before the foundation was soon inundated
with more pillowy pandemonium nobody was
safe from being the next victim of a
sudden ambush by scp-3832
not even a harmless unassuming
researcher like dr franklin prangley he
had just been going about his day
checking containment procedures were all
in place running a few tests on a few
scps the usual stuff for a scientist
working at site 64. that's when the call
went out over the com system it had
happened again
scp-3832 had vanished from the locker it
was usually kept secure in while on the
outside it looked like little more than
an ordinary cushion this anomaly was the
ultimate hunter displaying behavior
almost exactly like that of various
highly evolved ambush predators in the
wild and now this hunter was loose again
and it was open season on the foundation
staff this time it hadn't gone far
having only teleported to a different
part of site 64. as he would soon
discover the cunning cushion was hiding
just above dr prangley's locker waiting
for the researcher to return to his
office then when he was close enough scp
scp-3832 would strike but the next
would-be victim of the predatory pillow
had an advantage the location tracking
tag that the foundation had affixed to
the pillow proved to be its downfall
giving prangley an approximate fix on
its whereabouts gently pushing his
office door open he instantly spotted it
on top of his office locker ready to
pounce on him the moment he got close
enough slowly and methodically dr
prangley edged around his office
reaching for a meter stick he kept by
his desk with his chosen weapon in hand
the foundation researcher stepped closer
to his locker eyes fixed on scp-3832
he was brandishing the wooden meter
stick in both hands carrying it like an
early caveman with a handcrafted spear
at that moment dr franklin prangley was
locked in the dichotomy between predator
and prey that age-old dance a battle
that had raged for almost all of time
itself man versus pillow we've all been
there haven't we suddenly striking first
franklin took a sharp swipe at
scp-3832 with his meter stick he broke
out with a smile of glee as the pillow
was toppled from its vantage point it no
longer had the high ground over him
employing a swift offense as the best
defense the noble dr prangley had failed
scp-3832 in one quick pre-emptive strike
or so he thought as the old saying goes
pride goeth before the fall not sooner
had it landed in the heap on the office
floor then
scp-3832 launched itself back up and
limply hit franklin's square in the
stomach he let out a low grunt as the
pillow connected with his lower abdomen
and squeaked again announcing to the
world that
scp-3832 had just claimed its latest
victim dr prangley might never get over
that particular humiliation if he's
eaten by scp 682 in a week it will be a
merciful reprieve no one could end this
crafty cushions reign of terror to stand
against this goose feather-filled hunter
was to risk certain death well death by
embarrassment at least which some would
argue is honestly worse security officer
jennifer blair was never the same after
it happened to her it was waiting for
her behind the coffee machine in the
site 64 break room she'd gone in there
for a quick cup just to recharge her
energy levels with a boost of caffeine
before getting back to her posts
guarding the containment level poor jen
she never saw it coming
scp-3832 leaped from its latest hiding
place striking officer blair right in
her unprotected ankle the sudden vicious
attack from the polyester cover-wielding
persecutor caught her completely
unguarded which was somewhat ironic for
a member of the foundation's security
personnel but security officer jennifer
blake had no time to laugh at the irony
there punctuated by that same squeaking
sound the sudden impact of the pillow
colliding with her ankle caused her to
stumble not fall mind you she only lost
balance on one leg and was able to
quickly steady herself immediately after
but it was enough
just enough for her coffee to spill if
you need a moment to compose yourself
after that horrifying revelation we'd
understand it's one of the more
disturbing things we've shared on this
normally family-friendly channel leave a
comment with a key phrase
justice for jen so this poor scp
foundation security officer knows she's
in your thoughts and prayers after this
harrowing incident everyone okay now
okay good
back to the story at hand the incident
caused jen to suffer a few minor
first-degree burns on her hand and wrist
requiring a 15-minute treatment in the
site-64 infirmary which the medic
described as the worst relatively minor
burns i've ever seen while her external
injuries might not have taken much time
to heal now officer blake had to bring
instant coffee from home to work in a
thermos flask can you imagine such
horror it stretches the human
imagination to even compensate for the
level of terror it inspires in our
hearts and souls everywhere you looked
site-64 staff were being struck down
left right and center
mildly inconvenienced without warning by
non-lethal and mostly harmless ambushes
from scp-3832
during another relocation incident the
predatory pillow teleported itself back
to the location known as prs townhouse
in mclean virginia once again field
agent viola smithy was dispatched to the
scene to retrieve the elusive pillow
only this time she had learned from her
last encounter she brought back
specifically one other field officer
named gordon gompton to hopefully give
the cunning cushion its critical
comeuppance both field agents knew one
of them would have to take the hit and
gordon stepped up to the task after all
it had already got viola once before it
was his turn to face the nightmare that
was scp-3832
head-on they entered the townhouse agent
gompton taking the lead acting as a
human shield against any oncoming
pillowy projectiles just as they
expected and as it had before the ambush
took place not long after with
scp-3832 ineffectively hurling itself
from its hiding place but at the last
possible second gordon ducked out of the
way it was purely instinctive but it
left viola at the mercy of the oncoming
cushion it was a betrayal of truly
shakespearean proportions playing out in
real time marginally vexed at being hit
a second time with the pillow agent
smithy immediately decided to claim her
well-earned revenge grabbing the nearest
safe object which happened to be as
cp3832 itself she hurled it directly at
her fellow field operative it collided
with his head with another squeak the
combined sight and sound causing viola
to burst out laughing wearing a crafty
smirk gordon grabbed the pillow and
threw it back at her the same thing
happening the pair of them kept at it
repeatedly throwing
scp-3832 at each other again and again
every time the same squeaking filled the
air followed by more laughing from the
two agents as they continued their
pillowy fight
scp-3832 underwent a change that nobody
at the scp foundation had ever witnessed
before with every throw hitting either
agent smithy or agent gompton with its
characteristic squeaking noise the face
drawn on the post-it note that was
permanently stuck to
scp-3832 began to change usually the
sticky paper depicted a jagged
hand-drawn frowny face an upturned mouth
and eyebrows pointing inward in attack
formation a truly terrifying countenance
to behold
it also turned out that it was
impossible to remove the post-it note
without causing the pillow to teleport
again however when it was being thrown
about used in a pillow fight between two
foundation field agents joining in a
rare moment of childlike joy the face of
scp-3832 began to change the frown was
replaced with the unmistakable curvature
of a smile those angry attack eyebrows
completely vanishing as the pillow was
pleasantly pelted from agent viola
smithy to agent gordon gompton
eventually after they'd had their fun
the two operatives were duty bound to
return the now grinning cushion to the
foundation they reported their findings
to researchers many of whom seemed eager
to take part in tests replicating this
incident either because they were
looking to blow off some steam with a
nice wholesome pillow fight or because
they wanted to make scp-3832
smile again it didn't take long for the
fearsome piece of feathered filled
furniture to get back to its old tricks
though after all you can't teach an old
pillow new tricks and as for its next
unsuspecting victim the next would be
none other than director of site-64
himself one edgar palman that's right
not even one of the highest ranked
members of foundation staff stationed at
that particular facility was exempt from
falling prey to the dreaded pillow
having once again disappeared from the
confines of its locker
scp-3832 subsequently concealed itself
under the desk in director holman's
office laying in wait to pounce at its
prey as he pulled up his chair to sit
down the psych director was met with a
soft cushiony impact to his shins any
further up and it could have caused
serious damage he was lucky that
dastardly pillow didn't crease his
well-ironed slacks then there was the
relocation event that became known as
incident
3832-nr1
a few key differences set this
particular occurrence apart from the
others on
scp-3832's calamitous cacophony of
concealed cushioned carnage say that
five times fast for one it is what
directly led to the first of a few rare
instances of where the posted faced
pillow teleported itself to a location
now known as prs truffle the designation
given to saint john's chocolate factory
in portland oregon why is saint had a
chocolate factory we may never know but
i digress since becoming a potential
relocation site that
scp-3832 is able to teleport itself to
the factory had to be seized by the scp
foundation where it had once offered
tours to the public to present them with
all the wonders of the sweet tooth
process of making chocolate the gates
now remained closed with the false
promises that st john's chocolate
factory was under new management keeping
people out entire floors that could
easily be accessed by someone trying to
swipe a sample or two have now been
completely cleared out by the foundation
with not a stick of furniture left in
the place for anyone to steal or for
scp-38
to hide behind on the 14th of february
saint valentine's day 2017. foundation
technicians had been working on
repairing a glitch that had been
disrupting
scp-3832's tracking tag it was during
that moment that the wily polyester
pillow teleported out of its locker at
site-64 once again vanishing and
reappearing in the trunk of a car
belonging to a member of personnel now
for security reasons the name of the
staff member has been censored letting
her retain her anonymity and probably
whatever is left of her dignity too
we'll just call her big sister which is
how the file on the highly classified
scp archive refers to her up until this
point the researchers at the scp
foundation have never known
scp-3832 to have the ability to teleport
itself into a moving vehicle
teleportation is hard enough at the best
of times seriously you try shifting
every atom of your body from one spot to
another without getting stuck in a wall
and yet the crafty cushion made the
switch effortlessly relocating itself
into the back of big sister's car
without her noticing and to her credit
she had other things on her mind she
just finished a long day's work at site
64 and she needed to pick something up
for a special someone it was valentine's
day after all as she drove away big
sister was completely oblivious to the
fact that
scp-3832 could apparently now teleport
itself into moving vehicles the research
team studying the pillow and even the
security staff she passed at the front
gate were equally unaware making her way
further and further from site 64 big
sister pulled onto the freeway nervously
checking her watch she desperately hoped
she could get there in time before the
factory closed and that they'd still
have a box left they had to right who
sells out of chocolate on valentine's
day it's their biggest sales day of the
year safe for perhaps easter sunday
getting closer to saint john's chocolate
factory big sister could see from a
distance that the lights were still on
she relaxed in the driver's seat
breathing a sigh of relief that she'd
made it in good time her thoughts
quickly turned to her sweetheart
imagining the look of delight on their
face when she got home and presented
them with a shiny heart-shaped box
filled with a delicious assortment of
confectionaries parking up she dashed
inside the last person in before closing
time little did she know what was still
lurking in the trunk of her car like the
urban legend of the axe wielding killer
in the back seat with her romantic
holiday gesture of a box of chocolates
all paid for and tucked securely under
her arm big sister made her way back to
the car then a thought struck her a
terrible thought she couldn't just leave
this in the car the surprise would be
totally ruined if her significant other
could see what she'd got for them there
was only one thing for it the box of
chocolates needed to be hidden when she
got home and where else do you think to
hide something in a car in the trunk of
course as big sister unlocked the back
and lifted up the trunk lid a concealed
cushioned stealth attack of pure pillow
force struck her
scp-3832 launched itself from its hiding
place only to collide with the box that
big sis was carrying catching her
completely by surprise making its
signature squeak the predatory pillow
knocked the box sharply upwards into the
air and in a cruel twist of fate sent
the pointed edge of the heart straight
into big sister's face the tapered tip
was propelled straight into her mouth
chipping her front tooth as
scp-3832 landed on the ground of the
parking lot it was the most brutally
violent attack that
scp-3832 had ever conducted shocking
everyone at the scp foundation with a
cheer wonton ferocity making a call to
the scp foundation big sister requested
a recovery team to come and collect the
troublesome cushion after picking up the
present for her valentine and the
fragment of her tooth that it had rather
unceremoniously knocked out sighing she
leaned against the rear bumper of her
car keeping an eye on
scp-3832 while she waited for the
recovery team to arrive what a way to
spend valentine's day big sister thought
to herself worried about what her
partner would say when she got home late
with a chipped tooth then she noticed
something that while it didn't fix the
situation at least made her feel a
little less bad about it the post-it
note face of
scp-3832 had changed once again big
sister grabbed her phone from her pocket
to take a picture of it so she could
hand it over as evidence to the research
team instead of its normal frown
scribbled across the sticky note
scp-3832's hand-drawn expression had
become an almost bashful dimpled smile
with a big pair of cartoon hearts in its
eyes so if you take anything away from
this video it should be this gentle
reminder the chances of you being
ambushed and pounced upon by a pillow
with a post-it note for a face are well
statistically speaking the chances are
pretty slim but they're never zero
either you really should keep your wits
about you stay alert make sure you check
for movement when you leave every room
and look under tables and even in your
refrigerator just to be safe and if you
see something moving out of the corner
of your eye even just for a split second
then you too might just get hit in the
face by a pillow now why not go and
check out scp-999 the tickle monster and
scp-348 a gift from dad to get yourself
acquainted with a few of the more
adorable anomalies that the scp
foundation have encountered